like do you think that's out of sort of
like a fear mentality i think she's got
a lot of guilt yeah she's got a lot of
guilt where um she hasn't been able to
provide the way she wants to provide
yeah she's like i should be able to
help you with a mortgage help with the
marriage and we're like you essentially
solely raised six kids
um like we were all like at the point of
view where we're like hey it's our job
to look after you now like we turned 18
it's our job to retire you it's our job
to look after you she's got a lot of
guilt
and she's and i think it's more that
because of her guilt because of our care
for her that i'm like
do you know what if you don't wanna if
you don't wanna
ask to have kids i won't have kids but i
also i'm like
i'm too selfish at the moment and
selfish is a bad thing i'm too much like
if i ever never say never if i ever had
kids i'd want to be like i am happy to
commit all of my time i'm having to
sacrifice i'm happy to be like
financially you know you know what's
interesting they say that women around
like in their 30s all the ones that say
they don't want kids like start running
to a man i think apparently yeah yeah
like your biological clock apparently
like your hormones yeah like hey time as
well yeah
but like i would very happily adopt i i
was training as a social worker for a
little while um
and even that like
that is like um
you know there was a lot of good if you
want a family you can have a family you
don't necessarily have to have your own
kids yeah but it's not really practical
for the average person i don't know how
much money you make um not a lot no
so if you want to do like freeze your
eggs and have kids like that that's a
good and also adoption isn't cheap you
probably need like 20 grand to do that
like my parents adopted three kids so
it's actually um yeah it's not an easy
process no no yeah so for the average
person it's not really like well if you
want it bad well pregnancy isn't having
a family haven't that's it it's not
cheap it's not easy
but pregnancy like it's definitely
cheaper than both of those options
if you want a family bad enough yeah
finances and that's that's one reason no
i can't have a family because i'm like
financially
like that's i'm like no but if i wanted
it enough like i'd make it happen i
don't prioritize it do you ever um
so going back to like the body count
thing it doesn't matter to you do you
judge men if they care about it
like do you think they have a right to
want what they want um
i so i'm yeah opinionated but
nonjudgmental so i'm like you know just
because i won't feel the same way as i
do
i'm like i understand why someone's
point of view is their point of view
like it doesn't mean that i don't feel
[ __ ] about it like if a guy a guy once
was like i said to him i was like oh
i've done casual dating i've done casual
sex and he's like that's really
unattractive and what hurt me most is
that i was like well you didn't give me
a chance to say
like
of what i am now like you've judged me
on like
yeah but we judge man on their past all
the time
so if a guy said i was unemployed for
the last three years we would probably
judge him
yeah
and then she was just like oh do you
know what like does it really matter is
this gonna matter am i gonna cry about
this in two years time who who is this
man right yeah i mean a guy that you're
not committed to who cares i i
understand like his opinion doesn't mean
i literally had a single conversation
with as well and he was like it's not
attractive to me that you've done casual
dating and casual sex he was like have
you ever had a one night stand i was
like yeah i have and he was like that's
really unattractive and blocked me and i
was just at first like my ego my
self-esteem was a bit like what the [ __ ]
and then i was like okay but you've told
me that you go on a lot of dates and a
lot of first year but it's a double
standard oh yeah yeah yeah so i
i do think like men have the right to
judge us for that and i don't think like
women
we could say we judge men for it but
it's just not true like women women it's
um i mean you probably know a psychology
pre-selection
yeah so if a man gets a lot of women
like historically he he would have been
able to like take care of a lot of women
so it's attractive to us and we can't
undo our biology right we are how we are
even if it's unpractical in this day and
age well this is like animal the kingdom
um which is really funny um so you've
got like in the animal kingdom if the
lions the male lions you've got the big
mane it's the male peacock and there's a
liar birds it's the males who show off
all of their uh vocals it's uh there's a
bird i can't remember it's like a little
robin but it's the men and they
literally like create a nest and the
woman so a lot of it is the female
selection yes yes um
and i think in humans it's become a bit
like it's it's uh there's there's no
black and whites i would say in humans i
think it's the same thing the only
difference is that how we show our worth
as males is
you know if we take the vantage points
that we know that women are attracted to
successful men you go oh look at my
house look at my car yeah
the lifestyle that i'm living that is
all that's all the same as peacocking
basically for
for guys i would say
yeah yeah
but success is also very subjective and
it also depends on what it's not
subjective
i don't know because your income is like
very
very data driven but i would rather have
a man that knows about the ego and has
been through therapy and is like really
healthy than a man that's like so i've
dated a girl would you have you dated
have you dated a broke guy yeah yeah
yeah
why aren't you with them
um oh because of that what were you
talking about before the show
you broke up with him why
um
oh because
ambition not his money his ambition yeah
ambition and his inability to believe in
himself and make work
that's it
i grew up like when i i grew up in
poverty i understand i've dated very
well like a guy that had a lot of money
but like didn't didn't do much so i
understand what you're saying but we
can't we can't act like money is nothing
no yeah i'd rather make my own money you
know neo's misindependent like yeah she
won't let like she she wants amanda to
feed him i am so ferociously like i am
gonna have my own mortgage i'm gonna
have my own like i'm gonna be that [ __ ]
that's like i've secretly got money on
the side so if you want to leave me if
you want to cheat on me i'll be good i
would say that that's such a fear
mindset oh yeah yeah that's so silent
because yeah do you think decisions made
out of fear or good decisions
don't know
do i make good decisions i have a q i've
ever
have a question do you think
that the reason you don't care about
right now
how much a man makes is because you're
not looking to have kids right now
you're not looking to settle down but if
you were if you got to a point we're
like look i want to have a couple of
kids and you know as the woman you're
the one who bears the children right
you're the one who has to take time off
work
so you're gonna need a man who can
provide for you if you're gonna have at
least a reasonable comfortable life to
have kids so do you think that the
reason that you don't care about having
kids right now or you don't care about
whether a guy is broke
is because you're not going to settle
down whereas if you did you would care
100 and that's why like when i said that
if i had kids i'd want to be financially
responsible i want to be
um so 100 yeah like i agree with that
because
being selfish means that i can be
self-sufficient
but yeah if i had kids and i'm a very
big
i care more about other people than
myself so i'm like if i've got me that's
good that's cool but if i'm having kids
and especially like if you're and yeah
again my own history
my dad was a piece of [ __ ] and could not
finance you before i did all that kind
of stuff but um yeah like if if i was
gonna plan on having kids with a guy
i'd be like
yeah no like i need to know that you can
provide so yeah i would definitely make
a difference if i wanted to have kids
and if that was where i was at 100 yeah
so then if we can all agree that we
don't agree that most women want kids at
some point
yeah yeah so that means most women will
always care about how much a man will
make always
regardless how independent she is
regardless of where she sits on a
political spectrum whether she's
conservative or liberal whatever
if a woman wants to have kids with a man
and she wants to build a family she will
always care to some degree about how
much he can make